cinq ans après sa première vidéo que
devient le corps de cyprien comment
évolue-t-il que des questions que
personne ne se pose mais bon ça va pas
besoin d'être désagréable non plus merci
je me suis dit voilà j'ai dépassé 30 ans
c'est peut-être le moment de faire un
peu le bilan de vous expliquer un petit
peu les nouveautés quant à mon corps et
comment j'ai aussi perdu presque 10
kilos vous en parle à la fin de la vidéo
déjà je suis en très bonne santé et ça
c'est excellent ensuite les choses qui
ont évolué à queue en bien
malheureusement et des choses qui ont
pas du tout bougé je pense notamment la
transpiration excessive
mon corps en fait toujours des caisses
en termes de transpiration je sais
pourquoi
cyprien va se lever de sa chaise
j'envoie la formation lui a besoin de
moi non
[Musique]
c'est que si tu veux tu peux active est
juste un tout petit peu le virent oui
j'aime bien désolé la pilosité
ça ne s'arrange par ma barbe reprend du
terrain mes poils de torse aussi j'ai
l'impression que les deux veulent se
rejoindre pour je ne sais pas un moment
convivial torse on peut le perdre
quelques centimètres moizini breizh
on l'a fait je peux me joindre à vous de
bien sûr d'ailleurs en parlant de
pilosité
il faut que je vous l'avouer commence
aussi à avoir des poils sur les oreilles
c'est du duvet un peu dégueulasse qui
commence à avoir des poils un peu long
un peu blanc quand il ya du soleil c'est
pour avoir les oreilles de baby yoda
c'est pas la peine non merci alors moi
je demande tout simplement un service
après vente de mon corps au moins pour
poser des questions oui bonjour
installez vous ça vous a plu monosourcil
c'était mon idée on ça c'était une idée
de merde
à propos des poils moi je ne savais
froid non non j'ai un petit peu froid je
suis sûr on peut rajouter des poils pour
vous tenir au chaud devenir non je ne
veux pas plus de poils je vais bien j'ai
pas là vous avez oui mais là mais
forcément voulu mettre un ventilateur ça
n'a pas de sens voilà c'est parce que je
disais vous avez froid surtout aux
oreilles s'il vient rajouter des poils
aux oreilles la froid aux oreilles le
ponot on s'est un peu frileux des
orteils ou non j'ai froid pareil partout
au terme d'un poil je vous mets tout en
fait on regarde juste la paume des mains
ce joli coin ici élevé mettez des poils
partout sauf dans la paume des mains
ah oui petit fait surprenant chez moi
quand je baille je pleure parce que ça
veut dire c'est normal moi genre je
pleure beaucoup des grosses larmes qui
coulent sur les joues et d'ailleurs
depuis que je suis gamin collège au
lycée au travail mais arrivé plein de
fois cette situation mois le chat je
m'en bats les couilles mais ces choix de
ma meuf tu comprendras cyprien qu'est ce
qui t'arrive tu tu veux qu'on en parle
c'est un problème de coeur un problème
familial peut-être non je me fais chier
c'est tout tu veux pas en parler mais je
comprends ya plein de gens qui pensent
que je me mets à chicaner d'un coup
comme ça pas pourquoi j'ai autant de
larmes
c'est à cause de lui j'ai parce qu'il a
avec ce levier mais est ce une chômeuse
parlant des nouveautés et m'arrive un
truc assez bizarre en ce moment alors je
vous explique quand j'étais gamin
j'avais des pellicules tagish pina le
designer de cordes cyprien vous me
connaissez j'ai intégré un système de
particules qui tourne peu tes cheveux
their c'est pratique pour retrouver son
chemin quand il est perdu dans la foulée
bon ensuite j'ai utilisé du shampooing
antipelliculaire donc du coup c'était
réglé
qu'est-ce qui lé foot est mot 6ème
ingénieurs tombé à l'eau farouche
donc moi j'étais tranquille paix pouze
les années passent tout va bien hélas
depuis quelques temps je retrouve des
pellicules sur mes vêtements
mais tout ça vient c'est quoi ce bordel
les pellicules de barbe
tu n'as pas pu arriver c'est la nahia
rémois d'imposition des pellicules qui
tombe directement de la barbade a voulu
me la gueule on la fait pas à
c'est pas une blague
ma barbe fait des pellicules pourquoi ça
fait longtemps si quelqu'un a une
solution je suis preneur on reste dans
le poêle avec une question que pas mal
de gens se posent pas mal de mecs
surtout belges perdre mes cheveux
clairement pour moi il ya deux voies
possibles soit je deviens comme mon
grand père maternel beaucoup de cheveux
sur la tête n'y a pas de souci soit
comme mon père n'avait pas besoin de
schéma il reste plus grand chose désolée
papa tu es blue&me quand il ya du soleil
du coup je suis dans cette incertitude 1
je suis à un moment de ma vie où je suis
comme ça on sait pas trop surtout que
mon père ne met pas du tout car nantes
immo papa j'ai retrouvé une photo de toi
et pas tout hasard tu avec l âge dessus
genre où j'avais encore d'un peu de
cheveux je dirais 28 ans mais on était
plus jeunes comme andrew 35
ce principe à pattes avec elle je suis
chez plus entre le 25 et 35 soit précis
papa on s'en fout on se fout pas je peux
pas comprendre et coups de fils je
comprends tout à fait dis moi pas tu
avec l âge sur cette photo en noir et
blanc assez mois entre 10 et 40
tu seras jamais you never know my phone
parlons des changements depuis quelques
années j'ai perdu une dizaine de kilos
je passais deux à peu près 80 kg à 70 je
sais que les gens adorent les avants
après donc voilà avant après j'ai pas
spécialement changé mon alimentation
parce que chez moi les régimes ça marche
pas quand je me restreins d'ailleurs je
mange deux fois plus le lieu où tu
connais par contre j'ai changé quelque
chose dans mon quotidien
qu'est ce donc quel est son secret tout
le monde veut savoir est ce une
technique ancestrale roumaine va-t-il
partager avec nous cette information
incroyable
êtes vous prêt à découvrir la technique
ultime les médecins le déteste secret
dévoilé dans 3 2 petit suspense 1
je me déplace en vélo pas mal comme
secret c'est tout je vais au boulot à
vélo je vais mais rendez vous et une
vitesse incroyable a fait entre 40
minutes et 1h30 de vélo par jour je sais
que c'est décevant je n'ai pas de
programme secret je suis désolé ensuite
vient la question du muscle j'ai essayé
plusieurs procédés d'abord la salle de
sport cyprien youtube un jeu suite au
rejet direct et via cyprien duty plein
de la salle de sport ici c'est comme un
gros porc regard des sacs de loches bon
comme j'ai pu comprendre ça me
correspondait pas beaucoup alors
j'essayais un autre procédé la salle de
sport très cher mais contre ans observe
qui est là c'est le troubadour du web là
comme ils s'appellent normal faut que je
fasse un vidéogramme pour la cousinade
salut cassiopée s'agit balthazar
regardait qu'il a le conte d'internet la
hausse ensuite j'ai eu un coach à
domicile une fois par semaine et
maintenant pour me muscler
j'ai un nouveau truc que
j'ai un peu du mal à assumer j'avoue
voilages écran ce combat dure de ma
séance d'hier la brème aussi des
courbatures
armand duval non moi je fais du rite
dépenses toit tout en accomplissant des
objectifs ludique utilise ton corps pour
terrasser les monstres qui te barre la
route avec réplique non ok bah si en
même temps si tu te sens bien avec le
ring pays
je suis passé niveau 2 en faisant de
gainage félicitations aux qu'est ce
qu'on s'amuse tout en faisant une
activité sportive
on vous moquez pas pendant le
confinement moi ça va beaucoup aider
sanaa occupaient
d'ailleurs c'est pas un placement de
produit donc si nintendo voulait méfier
des thunes j'accepte quand même c'est
pas trop tard bon ben voilà maintenant
mon corps n'a plus de secret pour vous
le plus important je dirais que c'est
d'être bien dans son corps tout
simplement il faut l'assumer et pourquoi
pas un nouveau bilan dans quelques
années pour savoir comment ça évolue et
je perdre mes cheveux je me muscler
encore plus reprendre du poids on ne
sait pas en attendant abonne toi
[Musique]